[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right now ross tucker cbs westwood one
color analyst host of the ross tucker
football podcast and you can follow him
on social media at ross tucker nfl ross
good morning let's start with the the
trade and we probably have to wait a
couple of years i guess to assess this
but uh on face value
what part of the trade do you like or
not like
well it's it's funny dan because i i
don't like it in the near term for the
chiefs but
they're taking a longer time horizon
look at this thing right they're not
just looking at this year or the year
after they know they have patrick
mahomes as their quarterback for the
next 10 years
and i think they're trying to make sure
that they have a chance to play in more
conference championship games get to
more super bowls while they have mahomes
you know he signed a big contract
but it's actually going to end up being
pretty affordable it's not as much money
and as bad against the cap as people
think travis kelsey i think is
very underpaid i'm a little surprised he
signed the contract he did a year ago
that extension and i think the chiefs
kind of thought
that
tyreek hill would go along with it right
mahomes didn't get every penny he could
have kelsey didn't get every penny he
could have tyrae kill didn't get the
memo tyree kill didn't care
um he absolutely went for the most money
in going to south florida and more power
to him that's his prerogative but i
don't love it for the chief's chances of
winning the super bowl in 2022 i do
appreciate that andy reid and brett
beach realized it's not all about
2022 meanwhile dan for the dolphins
it kind of is a lot about 2022 right
yeah this is tua's third year they have
to make a decision on his fifth year
option
after this season they still have two
first-round picks next year
so the dolphins need to know
if two is the guy or not at the end of
this year if he is and they pick up the
fifth year option maybe they extend him
whatever if he's not they decline the
option
and very possibly draft another
quarterback next year with one of those
two first-round picks i think the
biggest football reason why the dolphins
got tyree kill is to basically enter on
armstead they get the left tackle dan
they get maybe the number one receiver
no excuses this is a no excuse season
for tua the dolphins want to have a
definitive answer at the end of 2022 on
their quarterback more likely to get
exposed and exposed as a tricky word to
use patrick mahomes or tyreek hill
probably tyree kill
yeah i think patrick mahomes is still
going to put up
30 points a game i think he's still
going to have a big year i don't know
that tyree kill with tuatango vialoa
is going to get as many of the deep
balls as he got i think one of the
reasons why the dolphins wanted tyree
kill is because
they know that
tuatangobilo doesn't really produce that
many explosive plays he's not mahomes
dan yeah but
tyrique turns those in to big plays so a
10 yard in and he can take it to the
house
so he does make he's going to make two a
better from the standpoint of you're not
going to throw it 60 yards but i'm going
to take it 60 yards
right and that's where they got him if
you look at it though
tyrique hill caught more deep balls from
the homes than people i mean a lot of
those were
deeper throws down the field and he blew
past people the best thing tyreek hill
has going for him is mike mcdaniel the
new head coach in miami he knows
better than anybody in the nfl he and
kyle shanahan how to get the ball
to their run after catch guys
in stride so they can run after the
catch i mean you look at debo samuel
even at times ayuk they do an
unbelievable job in san francisco of
getting the ball to those guys on the
move with some space and then they know
what to do with it that's the thing that
gives tyreek hill a chance to still be
super productive is i think mcdaniel's
going to be able to give him the ball a
lot on some of those slants
we had chris sims on yesterday and i
said who do you like better tyree kill
or uh
uh devante adams
you knew who he picked
probably tyrique hill yeah i think i saw
it on twitter
yeah what do you make of it let me check
my script
i sent you like come on let me see what
i'm saying i said you're supposed to
slam the table it says on the script
uh i'm supposed to say no i did not see
who chris sims picked in can you tell me
he picked tyreek hill
now you slammed the table you
you slammed you didn't like it no you
slammed the table that's right
on the script yeah
i disagree with that dan i disagree with
you then you call out chris sims and you
call him a pretty boy that's what the
script says
you know
in all sincerity
i don't think he's a better receiver
than devonte adams
i think he provides more value
for a team than devonta adams and i'm
going to try to explain that right
as route runner in the nfl
i think he's incredible
tyree kill
is someone that dictates defensive
coverage every play adams does a little
bit but adams
is not a guy that's going to take it to
the house all the time not a guy that
puts
that much fear and
cornerbacks don't like going against
devante adams because he makes him look
bad and he can get a nice 15-yard gain
whatever
tyree kill just embarrasses people i
mean he's the fastest foot dan i i mean
i'm 43 years old i was in the nfl since
2001. he's the fastest football player
i've ever seen
and i'm not sure who's close
it's breathtaking
how fast he is compared to nfl defensive
backs
yeah i was wondering when you see
somebody in person i always bring up
this story when i was at the olympics in
london
and i got to see usain bolt in person oh
it's it's it's completely different than
watching him on tv because you're
watching you know tv stays focused on
him when you're watching it's like it's
like cgi you're going
you're just moving down the track
watching tyreek hill in person it's
it just is night and day difference than
watching on tv by the way dan i i got a
usain bolt take for you are you ready
yeah
i think he's the most impressive athlete
of all time and here's why i say that
okay
any nfl guy tom brady whatever that's
great
but there's a million kids that play
high school football in like the whole
world right in america and i'm sure
there's some in the uk or whatever and
then soccer there's a lot of people play
soccer michael phelps crazy impressive
but a lot of people don't try to be
swimmers
everybody in the whole world
billions of people
has run at some point like you know if
you're fast or not at some point you had
to run africa
asia what you run so you know if you're
fast or not
of every single human being in the world
all of whom knows if they're fast or not
usain bolt is still that much faster
than every other human being
that to me is by far the most impressive
physical feat
forget lebron michael jordan i mean
that's all that's great but for usain
bolt to be that much faster than every
other human being on the entire planet
is crazy
paulie scripted that you read it quite
well
and uh um if everybody in the history of
mankind lined up at a starting line for
100 meters usain bolt wins
yes
by a decent amount i mean i need a big
track to get everybody in the history of
mankind to run the 100 meter dash but
imagine that
is there is there any anything else
where you go that guy will be the number
one guy
so the fastest person who's ever walked
the earth
is there any other category where you go
if you lined up everybody
uh this person's going to be
you know heads above the rest with
everybody in the history of mankind
no because the thing is like any other
sport you talk about a lot of people
have never played basketball a lot of
people never played baseball like and
all that's impressive like literally
every human being that's ever lived he's
that much faster it's hard to believe
actually right like there's billions of
people with a b billions and when you
watch him at the olympic stand and you
were there he blows away he blows away
the nine other fastest dudes
all right before i let you go which team
had the best month dolphins broncos
buccaneers browns raiders other
which team had the best month
give to me again
broncos
buccaneers
browns who were introducing desean
monson today
raiders
or other
denver broncos
i'm going to say denver broncos i'll
tell you why
they had no quarterback for what was it
six years seven years
and they're gonna have russell wilson
more than likely oh by the way they're
gonna have to pay him so much money next
year it's not even funny i know i like
how people go we got russ i go you still
got to pay him about 50 million dollars
a year oh yeah he sees the desean watson
contract he sees the aaron rodgers deal
the broncos screwed that up by the way
they should have gotten him signed when
they traded him like devante adams like
tyreek hill but that's a story for
another day but it's right it's the
broncos look it's huge for the bucks
franchise that brady's back i get that
right
but it's only going to be a year or two
we think
the broncos should have russell wilson
for the next decade i mean
and i still believe he's a top 10
quarterback i wouldn't be surprised if
we think he's still a top five
quarterback i think he played better
last year than people realize to go from
not having a top 20 quarterback
for
a good six seven years in denver to
having a probable top five guy
for a decade uh is a huge huge swing i
guess you could say the same
about cleveland but i i can't
i can't equate those two i can't say
what cleveland did
especially with that i just can't say
that that's as good as what denver did
because to me there's still a decent
amount of unknown with the desean watson
situation
have a great weekend always great to
talk to you thanks for following the
script today ross
thank you for having me dan you have a
great weekend also
that's ross tucker cbs westwood one
color analyst host of the ross tucker
football podcast you can follow him on
social media at ross tucker nfl